[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de
lacan ou une histoire française de la
psychanalyste il faudrait plus d'une
émission pour évoquer la personnalité du
docteur lacan psychanalyste et
intellectuels français à qui l'on doit
le mérite d'avoir prolongé l'oeuvre et
la clinique de freud en la féconde en de
sa propre pensée si le savant viennois
créé la psychanalyse il y a un style
lacan qui a permis de pérenniser en
france et à l'étranger
la science des rêves et de l'inconscient
en la dotant d'un discours analytique
complètement inédit et qui suscita
l'admiration des grands esprits de son
temps michel foucault claude lévi
strauss romane jacobson louis althusser
et de nombreux artistes picasso dali
fellini woody allen et plus près de nous
arnaud desplechin lacan ne résume pas à
lui tout seul l'histoire française de la
psychanalyse mais il est sans conteste
une figure majeure inégalée nous le
verrons il est en tout cas l'esprit le
plus original jusqu'à paraître décalé
baroque
extraterrestre même temps il suscita
admiration et controverses décédé en
1981 quand a transmis sa pensée avec ses
écrit et oralement à travers de nombreux
séminaires son héritage demeure vivant
en france et à l'étranger au sein de la
psychanalyse comme dans le champ de la
culture et des arts mais à en croire ses
fidèles comme ceux qui le contestent le
monde est plein d'idées lacanienne
devenue folle c'est le destin des grands
innovateurs pour en parler je vous
présente mes invités jacques adam
hilaire vous êtes psychanalyste et
fondateur de l'école de la cause
freudienne boris cyrulnik vous êtes
neuropsychiatre écrivain catherine
millot est psychanalyste et écrivaine
daniel mesguich vous êtes metteur en
scène et ancien directeur du
conservatoire
[Musique]
commençons par lacan intime lacan in
time dans l'homme était à la fois
moderne et dans son temps commençons par
l'homme en chair et en os qui était
jacques lacan quels traits dominants
dans le portrait de famille du futur
grand intellectuel et cliniciens de
génie jacquat lumière écoutez dans
l'intimité il était très gentil
et on en a le témoignage dans le volume
que j'ai fait paraître cette année
on a le témoignage de ces deux personnes
espagnol qui tenait sa maison de
campagne où ils allaient tous les
week-ends où il passait le mois d'août
et vous verrez l'homme charmant
tranquille apaisé respectueux des autres
qu'il est dans son exercice
professionnel
c'est plus technique et sa fidèle
secrétaire gloria explique que toutes
les portes du 5 rue de lille où il
exerçait son fendiller parce qu'il ait
claqué et ensuite elle éclate et aussi
donc
c'était un peu démoli ce que vous diriez
la même chose catherine millot ou qu'il
avait bien connu enfin oui je les côtoie
y est je l'aï accompagné pendant vingt à
partir de 60 72 c'est à dire ça date
d'il ya 50 ans c'est aussi à ce moment
là que j'ai rencontré jacques alain
miller c'était il ya 50 ans
oui l'accord était quelqu'un de très
gentil et cc je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec saint phalle et met
d'ailleurs il disait vous avez un
souvenir précis de qui montre à quel
point il était gentil
pour étayer cette idée parce que là on a
une image de la confronte à ce qu ils
venaient revenez l'un d'eux qu'ils
étaient aussi ils pouvaient inattendu et
ses pairs mais ses commandes et colère
c'était ça n'était pas contre les
personnes c'était plutôt contre les
éléments contre les choses ou en retard
de taxi ou 20 ou où un feu rouge ou mais
ça n'était pas dirigée contre les
personnes et c'était quelqu'un aussi qui
avait cette particularité de ne pas
refaire de ne pas vous faire de
critiques ni critique ni reproche la
seule critique qu'il m'ait fait on quand
même plusieurs années de fréquentation
c'était que je n'en faisais qu'à ma tête
alors il faut dire que que j'ai moi je
pensais que c'était normal n'en faire
qu'à sa tête fut d'ailleurs lui je pense
qu'il joue sinon faisait qu'à sa tête à
notre avis daniel mesguich un personnage
comme la camp dont on sait qu'ils
avaient un côté baroque dans son
esthétique vous qui êtes metteur en
scène qui connaissent m il avait en il
souhaitait apparaître comme un artiste
aussi c'est une dimension artistique du
personnage et vous savez on va rapporter
un copeau de benoît jacquot qui a tourné
des metteurs en scène de cinéma et
benoît jacquot part et il aurait dit que
lacan était un grand acteur
je pense que non je pense que non pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
objectivement la voix très faible avec
les finales qui se perdent des tambours
légendaire entre ventre mou et un autre
mot qui dure trois heures et demie on
entendait pousser l'herbe pendant qu'il
se taisait
le fait de se moque éperdument de savoir
s'il était entendu ou pas le tout
c'était de le dire il disait peu importe
si les gens le prennent et c'est donc
non je pense que tu es pas un grand
acteur du tout mais benoît jacquot
disait que c'était un contacteur parce
qu'il mélangeait de choses le grand
intellectuel jacques lacan
indéniablement et et acteur parce qu'il
l'avait filmée il faut pas mélanger les
choses donc encore à mon avis non boris
cyrulnik un petit souvenir
est-ce que vous pouvez rappeler juste un
souvenir vous avez rencontré jacques
lacan oui je les rencontrerai le ses
souvenirs de la rencontre on rentrera
d'après dans le voilà ils étaient amis
c'était un excellent chef de clinique il
était ami avec robert messimy qui était
mon assistant quand j'étais interne en
neurologie à paris et il venait parler
de neurologie avec messi bideau c'est un
lacan un peu atypique que j'ai rencontré
bien on aura l'occasion d'en parler mais
jacques alain miller bruit je voudrais
expliquer à daniel mesguich pourquoi
benoît jacquot a dit ça
benoît jacquot a réalisé la seule
émission de télévision que lacan a
accepté parce que simplement rencontré
une fois benoît jacquot il a eu de la
sympathie pour les immédiate
alors là quand s'est présentée dans le
studio de la poser une question il a
commencé à répondre dans le style que
vous décrivez ce qui n'allait pas du
tout pour phil b et donc j'ai dit
docteur il va falloir que vous écriviez
vos textes et pendant une semaine tous
les soirs la porte et gentiment ce qu'il
avait écrit pendant la journée pour dire
comme il était gentil et ensuite il a dû
interpréter ce texte il a joué et je
pense que c'est pour soi que benoît
jacquot dit que c'était un grand acte
d'autre part à son séminaire qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui n'en perdait pas une seule
qui est allé à tous ces séminaires et
qu'il a dit qui m'a reproché de ne pas
avoir filmé c'est
séminaire c'est philippe sollers alors
je vais aller un peu plus loin avec vous
jacana muller on connaît vos liens de
famille avec la quand vous avez poussé
son gendre aux êtres gens ne sait pas
forcément à la haye vous avez poussé sa
fille une de ses filles judith
on connaît la célèbre apostrophe de jean
paul sartre famille je vous hais il
semble qu'avec là quand ce soit
différent recharges quoi cegid âge est
saisie vous voyez une confusion mais
sartre était un peu sur le même registre
du il est élaboré sa mère oui mais il
arrivait le processeur saponé sait pas
très bien si l'allusion vire milliards
et sartre quand j'avais 16 ans il m'a
ouvert la porte et il y avait sa mère
dans l'appartement ben alors les
relations de lacan avec sa propre
famille c'était quoi
ma femme a raconté qu'elle a vu mon père
pleurer une seule fois à la mort de sa
mère
il a écrit très gentiment à son père
noël témoignage dans le volume est sorti
quand il avait 17 ans mon petit papa s
était
il à eau de plus il avait un frère
prêtre dont on va parler juste et il a
entretenu avec lui une correspondance et
il avait pour le frère ou marque
beaucoup d'affection
pour sa fille judith infâme
il est je crois qu'on peut dire qu'elle
était sa préférée saisie ne l'empêché
pas de fréquence d'aller voir ses
enfants du premier est ce que vous même
et judith vous est-ce que vous l'aviez
vous le vous soyez ou vous le tutoyer
tous les deux nous utilisions le vous
pour s'adresser elle a son père -
beauvais vient alors écoutez poursuivant
un petit peu le canevas lacan intime
pour savoir ce qu'il pense et j'ai calé
muller vient de parler de son frère qui
était dominicain je pense il n'y avait
pas l'ombre d'une croyance religieuse
chez lacan sans pour autant négliger la
lecture des textes religieux il disait
l'athénée pas celui qui dit dieu mais
celui qui ne hier aucun dieu c'est quand
même très différent est ce que cette
subtilité plus profane qu'anti
chrétienne montre
son relation à la chrétienté en religion
et il n'était pas un athée classique
qu'est ce que vous en pensez catherine
millot je pense que sur l'athéisme il
avait dit que ce n'est pas d'être athées
se dit d'ailleurs un peu comme ça entre
qui disent un peu la même chose et raté
c'est un long travail et en pour lacan
l'athéisme ne pouvait être atteint dès
est il qu'au terme d'une longue à 16 pic
analytique c'est ça que je retiens c'est
à dire c'est
qu'au fond ça peut s'atteindre
l'athéisme mais au terme d'un long
travail et d'une longue à 16 qu'est ce
que vous en pensez boris cyrulnik
j'ai côtoyé rené girard qui était propre
kit français professeur aux états unis
et qui aimait beaucoup la camp et qui
l'a invité à venir aux états unis et
illac ans et il est rentré en amérique
du nord et du sud plus par rené girard
que par son frère dominicain coûté jeu
là quand il beaucoup de mal à entrer aux
états unis et ça n'est pas encore fait
pour ma part je crée une association
mondiale de psychanalyse qui est
la seconde le second réseau
psychanalytique mondial après l'ipea
créé par produit même et nous sommes 10
% seulement des ses mains mais nous
sommes très présent en amérique latine
en europe mais pas en allemagne derrière
n'est en outre ij pour des raisons
la législation de ces pays et aux états
unis très peu présent et un tout petit
groupe
au fond la personne
je puis dire qui est héritière de
quelque chose de l'accord mais dans ce
sens que vous avez des idées lacanienne
devenue folle c'est judith butler
celle qui a inventé bien accueilli mais
la théorie du genre est sur le point de
la religion vous dirais qu'il était plus
agnostique caté parce que il y avait sa
culture religieuse et n'est pas nul a
pas du tout elle a eu beaucoup
d'importance pour lui
il a été élevé au collège stanislas
il il connaissait très bien les pères de
l'église
l'évangile
lui reprocher là dessus et d'ailleurs
les jésuites avaient parié sur la camp
contre les autres gourous
psychanalytique et en particulier la
société paris si bien qu'il y avait 12
dans l'école de lacan qui à partir d'un
certain moment on était déçu quand lacan
a mis en avant la logique mathématique
au moment où il a commencé à enseigner à
l'école normale à l'invitation de
l'horizon il très à l'invitation
d'althusser et donc les jésuites ont été
très déçus et manque de chance pour moi
et moi attribué ce changement population
alors que vraiment je n'y étais pour
rien mais sur le plan religieux est ce
exact qu'il aurait dissuadé son frère
d'aller dans les ordres comme on dit oui
c'est exact pour ce que j'en sais en
effet ils pensaient que c'était pas la
meilleure façon
de ce comment dire valoriser ses talents
ceci dit une fois que le choix était
fait il a tout à fait respecté pour la
question que vous me posez tout à fait
d'accord et catherine moi je me souviens
d'une phrase où il adressé à son
séminaire où il mettait tout le monde au
défi de prouver qu'il ne croyait pas en
dieu alors peut-être au père noël de la
religion will daniel mesguich
je le disais tout à l'heure à boris
cyrulnik jeu je joue ici le le candide
de services puisque je ne suis pas un
ali je ne suis pas cliniciens je la mets
mais le peu que je sais de lacan le peu
qu'on dit compris
me fait penser qu'il était athée comme
seul un catholique peut l'être
c'est à dire que son athéisme des
catholiques alors je ne sais pas je veux
pas me lancer dans des temps des martyrs
dans les parages trop théorique que je
ne pouvais d'ailleurs pas mener jusqu'à
leur terme sans doute mais mais le réel
lacanien c'est le paradis nous c'est une
sorte de paradis chrétiens et et je
crois moi moi ça valait vraiment
original je ne le savais pas je ne
savais pas que lacan était athée et je
vais toujours lui comme un catholique
comme rené girard d'ailleurs enfin comme
un catholique enfin qui clique qui est
intelligent donc qu'il n'est pas dans la
foi d ati du lot bien entendu mais enfin
que soient les couilles je sais pas s'il
était apte et à proprement parler il a
dit dieu est inconscient c'est bien ce
que je voulais dire est congolais course
à weave le script mais je crois pas
compliqué s'il était apte et c'est pas
comme les autres
de la religion à la politique et à une
passerelle aujourd'hui au
attendant à dire qu'on n'est ni de
gauche ni de droite et de gauche et
droite est-ce que catherine millot
penser que là quand on sait pas s'il
était à gauche ou à droite
mais s'il était du côté freudien vous
avez froid il disait la politique vous
gâche le caractère est ce que vous
diriez qu'il était en ce sens freudien
enfin pour ce que je peux dire en tout
cas ce qu'ils lisaient le figaro
pendant la guerre d'algérie où elle
avait l'express et l'observateur c'est
sa pensée je pense que son côté de
gauche c'était d'avoir soutenu
le mouvement de libération
algériens et puis cela plus tard je
dirais que tu te dis mais dans la
famille qu'on a beaucoup
il souhaitait la ruhr la payer delà des
prisons pour ce qui est du cousin de
judith diego masson le chef d'orchestre
qui a passé trois ans en prison pour ai
deux auraient fait laine
là que judith à 17 ans est entré dans la
danse le docteur lacan savait
parfaitement ce qui se passait chez lui
n'a jamais dit un mot contre c'est trop
dire qu'ils soutenaient
ouais mais rien fait contre les
engagements de sa fille donc il essaie
il était moderne avant le d'un avant
aujourd'hui puisqu'on passe de
l'observateur on figaro c'est bien ça
mais je pense aussi que il avait quand
même soutenu activement laurence qui a
été qui a fait de la prison laurence
vous pointez
trois mois seulement et il lui adresser
la faute aux côtés de son séminaire de
l'équipe de la psychanalyse oui j'ai vu
l'exemplaire de laurence qui était à mon
antigone boris cyrulnik parce que lacan
était maurrassien pape par amour de la
linguistique
parce qu'il ça lui permettait de
découvrir la langue comme il l'a
retrouvée ensuite avec jacobson donc ce
n'était pas tellement par amour de
l'idéologie mais c'était par amour de la
langue oui ça me paraît discutable on a
une lettre de madame daudet m
adresser à maurras qui dit qu'elle a
rencontré un jeune homme plein de feu
qui s'appelle jacques lacan et qui
voudraient aller en afrique
développer répandre la bonne doctrine
donc c'est pas exactement un amoureux de
la langue telle qu'il s'était en tout
cas présenté à madame léon daudet mais
alors par donc merci juste un mot est en
passe à la halle en question plutôt un
jardin minarets mais alors comment vous
expliquez que tous les bas aux east des
années 70 c'était bleus d'amour pour la
corde écoutez comme jacques alain miller
par ailleurs était assurée c'est dans sa
jeunesse qu'il a été maurrassien comme
moi juge aux east on ne s'arrête pas
forcément
à ses engagements de jeunesse brillé
l'an cohen l'a poursuivie comme homme de
droite à sa façon et moi entre
guillemets comme homme de gauche bien
que j'ai dit il ya déjà plusieurs années
que l'homme de gauche étaient morts
[Musique]
la psychanalyse lacanienne c'est d'abord
un discours inédit avec des métaphores
qui s'enchaînent et qui éclaire la
personnalité du sujet on a pu dire que
c'est une pensée qui autorise à penser
ça vous a autorisé à penser catherine
millions
c'est là qu'en comme personne qui avait
été un homme qui donne une idée de ce
que c'est qu'être libre et être libre
c'est cette façon c'est rendre libre les
autres est en tout cas ce que j'ai
trouvé et
expérimenté à ses côtés c'était de que
que sa liberté me rendais libre mais en
vous rendant libre ça vous autoriser à
penser plus librement avancer les choses
c'est le summum autorisé à dire ce que
je pensais en tout cas par exemple lors
quelqu'un vous plaisait pas vous
l'envoyer balader commença à quai
c'était quoi
oui mais des exemples non parce que les
c'est intéressant de savoir
cet effet-là sur la pensée comment ça
autorise à penser la psychanalyse
lacanienne et le personnage emblématique
de lacan c'était quelqu'un qui n'en
femmes il faut dire qu'il était analyste
et que c'était quelqu'un qui ne vous qui
ne vous sont serait jamais des gens
enfin c'est qu'ils vous laisser on en
effet entièrement entièrement libre
aussi
dans son exercice et dans le discussions
privées tout à fait oui qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
boris cyrulnik
vous qui êtes médecin c'est pas là dix
ans la quintessence du médecin que
quelqu'un autorise à penser en écoutant
eux
j'étais contraint à découvrir lacan
parce que je suis un arc et aux
psychiatres j'ai été diplômé avant 68 et
c'était l'époque où pour devenir
psychiatre on apprenait la neurologie
donc j'ai été reçu à l'institut de
psychologie avait un concours à cette
époque là j'ai été reçu par ce que le
question pour réciter la moelle épinière
donc les psychologues et les
psychanalystes était assez moyen sur la
branlée pinière donc il y avait une
organisation de l'absurde et la seule
manière d'essayer de comprendre les
autres c'est-à-dire de leur donner la
parole c'était la psychanalyse donc je
pas pu échapper à freud et lacan j'en
suis pas mécontent mais ça fait partie
de la formation d' été contraint parce
que c'était la neurologie ou les la
psycho ou l'avez lu à partir de quelle
époque
64 j'étais nommé je commençais à dire la
canche 64 quand vous étiez à l'époque
interne voilà c'est ça j'étais dès cette
période vous l'avez lu voilà j'étais
interne en neurologie et ou bien on
conte expliqué la schizophrénie par la
neurologie ce qui était très critiquable
ou bien on cherche à trouver une
solution dans la psychanalyse et tous
les internes aller chercher la solution
parce formant la psychanalyse en feu de
façon pouvant justement créé notre
parole et l'échangé avec les autres
jacques alain miller sur cette autorise
à penser il vous apporter quelque chose
dans ce domaine là non je m'étais
autorisé à tous aller avant de lire la
con
à propos de ce qu'il arrêtait ou non
sauf exception il n'arrêtait pas les
gens dans leurs projets les moins bien
avize
afin que ils fassent eux mêmes
l'expérience
de ce collier contre un réel et qui ne
s'abrite pas derrière l'interdiction
qu'il aurait été formulée par un m
d'ailleurs cet homme que catherine et
moi nous avons dit très gentil est aussi
celui qui disait je n'ai pas de bonnes
intentions ce qu'on a mal pris mais ça
veut simplement dire que l'enfer est
pavé de bonnes intentions et que lui
n'avait pas l'intention de paver l'enfer
qu'est ce qui vous a apporté avoue
daniel mesguich même si vous n'êtes pas
praticiens mais vous avez lu là quand je
suis pas travestir mais j'entends le mot
faire que katherine sa prononcer tout à
l'heure vous ne voulais en faire qu'à
votre tête
c'est une phrase de psychanalyste
je crois que ça m'a beaucoup apporté
enfin encore une fois de manière
indirecte parce que je n'étais pas
connecté absolument au texte de l'accord
même si j'ai beaucoup lu les séminaires
que vous avez transcrit j'ai beaucoup
j'ai essayé de lire aussi les actrices
beaucoup plus plus loin de moi
mais mais mais je je pense que ça m'a
beaucoup aidé parce que ça m'a ça m'a
aidé comment dire à alors vous avez dit
libre c'est pas le mot que j'emploierais
mai mais en tout cas à entendre avoir
une oreille plus exercer tout simplement
enfin quant au mot frog
m'a fait découvrir nous visons ce qu'on
appelle au théâtre l'intériorité voilà
c'est à dire la conscience sans doute
mais l'intériorité au théâtre et est là
qu en a fait entendre davantage les
moules les signifiants les phrases elle
même qui a été prononcée dans les textes
en fait c est donc oui ça va ça va
beaucoup apprendre à écouter je vais
prendre une série d'expressions
lacanienne qui pour le commun des
mortels apparaissent absconse et vous
allez vous dire entre quelques mots ce
que ça signifie ou alors j'en ai pris
quelques unes le par lettre jean calas
1000 r ça veut dire goûter c'est très
simple lettre parle en eux et s'est
contracté et au lieu d'avoir deux mots
vous avez vous en avez un seul qui est
évidemment un néologisme très difficile
à traduire dans les autres langues bien
très bien alors à vos boris cyrulnik le
des êtres
qu'est ce que vous entendez par là alors
je n'entends pas parce que c'est la
première fois j'entends cette expression
mais des êtres je veux notre avis ça
peut vouloir dire quoi je dirais que
pour nous dans la mythologie
la condition du vivant c'est d'être mais
que nous êtres humains il ya être
biologiquement et en plus y'a être par
la parole donc quand on ne parle pas on
en parlait tout à l'heure quand il ya
des êtres humains qui parce qu'ils ne
vivent sans mots ce sont les aphasiques
ce sont les bébés ce sont les malines
malades d'alzheimer il reste humain mais
reste dans un monde humain sans paroles
ce qui est assez difficile à comprendre
est absolument passionnant dont je pense
que là il ya un des êtres séquence qu'il
ya un désert pendant un désert pendant
la période du conte vite par exemple
alors je redis que d existence dans la
période du convie les gens et c'est pas
si compliqué le d le suffixe et ça
exprime un certain mode de la négation
prenez le titre bien compréhensible de
jean paul sartre l'être et le néant eh
bien disons que des êtres est entre les
deux bien alors catherine millot avec
vous je vais prendre une autre
expression un désir sans détour un désir
sans détour mais je suis contente que
vous utilisez c'était parce que c'est ça
le leur le rapport de la quant au désir
ça c'est quelque chose qui m'a toujours
il début vraiment
époustouflés enfin je pensais aussi
épaté je pense aussi que jacques alain
comme moi ils étaient épatés par lacan
mais on est épaté par cette dimension
vers son rapport au désir
il a dit d'ailleurs que que mon la seule
faute morale c'est céder sur son désir
est lui c'était on le voyait à l'oeuvre
dans son rapport à son désir et ce qui
était frappant chez lui c'est à la fois
c'est qu'il y avait son rapport aux 10
au désir comme fondamental c'est à dire
son rapport à son métier d'analyste son
rapport à son enseignement qui nous
essaie de le de le préoccuper de le
21e avoir enfin et il y avait son
rapport aussi au puzzle à ce que
j'appellerai les petits désirs et ça
c'était quelque chose de formidable de
voir comment ils pouvaient être
respectueux du moindre petit désir de
l'été personnes avec lesquelles il se
trouvait avec lesquels il était né lui
aussi il a dit oui pour que le
psychanalyse se garde d'être angoissé il
faut toujours qu'il y ait un petit
détail et par exemple ces petits désirs
c'était de filer chez son libraire de
livres anciens qui est dans ce volume et
puis d'acheter un livre ancien et de
retourner très vite dans son bureau plus
précisément au prix généralement il a
dit une fois que le désir comporte
toujours une défense contre le désir et
bien il ya au moins un sujet qui n'avait
pas ses défenses contre le désir et
selim avait pour daniel mesguich une
autre expression mais qui a beaucoup de
sens aujourd'hui
il disait la vérité pas tout dans cette
période où chacun croit à une vérité
tout qu'elle s'exprime pour vous la
vérité pas tout c'est pas cette
expression seul c'est dans un contexte m
ce que j'imagine moi c'est que quand on
montre quelque chose quand on pointe un
endroit qu'on croit être de la vérité et
ben notre doigt est trop gros et donc
qu'on leur cache en même temps qu'on
montre on cache
mais ça me paraît très juste la seule
chose que je regrette ici l ilm allait
noyer que vous n'avait convoqué aucun
ans qui l'atteignent il n'ya plus d'anti
la gagner encore dos au but il n'ya plus
d'anti la salle il n'y a plus il à
plumes mais la question que le plus que
vous posez cette question en essayant si
vous voulez d'établir un nouveau langage
qu'est ce que voulait véritablement
exprimé lacan parce que coûte et il
voulait c'est tabou de lui serrer
ce dont il s'agit dans la psychanalyse
et il avait aussi l'idée s'il écrivait
de façon que lui même a a dit il lisible
pas ali c'est qu'ils avaient la même
ambition que john jay joris qui avait
dit j'occuperai les universitaires
pendant 300 les lecteurs pendant 300 ans
et l'idée c'est que évidemment l'objet
petit add a pas eu le succès de la
résilience de monsieur cyrulnik mais là
quand parier excusez moi que dans 300
ans on ne lirai plus monsieur cyrulnik
excusez moi et qu'on continuerait de le
lacet une attaque fraternelle qu'est ce
que vous en pensez borie cyrus ne
retrouvera dans 300 ans pour en parler
bon y'a vous pour vous il ya un lien
entre l'objet petite taille la
résilience
dont eddy de 10 de nuit ce quel objet
petite aja calvin r feront l'objet
petits tas c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
résiliente dans le par lettre voilà donc
ça va ça vous va complètement
je pense que la définition de la
résilience elle est bête elle est
fondamentale parce que mes bêtes c'est
la reprise d'un nouveau développement
après un traumatisme dont je pense qu un
psychanalyste forcément accepte cette
définition puisqu'il y travail sérieux
psychiatre psychanalyste un facteur
c'est pas la résilience mais participe
est un facteur de résilience mais dans
la résidence il ya plusieurs facteurs il
ya les cinq sens biologique dont la
quant à parler dans sa terre et il ya
les facteurs biologiques il ya surtout
bien sûr là ce dont on parle c'est à
dire la 10e par lettre et puis aussi une
application c'est que lacan en entrant
dans la culture permis de communiquer le
l'idée que l'on pouvait travailler à
s'en sortir et que avance que je connus
moi quand j'étais en formation quand je
connaissais rien alors que maintenant je
crois connaître un peu donc un grand
progrès et quand j'étais hors formation
on nous apprenait que s'étaient fixés
c'est à dire c'était l'époque fixiste
quand quelqu'un qui a traumatisé une
pouvait pas s'en sortir quand quelqu'un
était part d'un traumatisme à tizi ouzou
et pas s'en sortir c'était une pensée
fixiste et la psychanalyse le
l'éthologie animal tout la neurologie
d'aujourd'hui montrent qu'au contraire
la plasticité et elles mêmes le nez pour
vous boris cyrulnik la résilience après
un traumatisme
ça passe par la parole
ça passe par le soutien affectif et la
parole c'est à dire ça pastore une
parole qui exprime le leader en quelque
sorte d un désir du sujet c'est à dire
qu'il faut pas que ce soit la parole de
l'autre qui viennent le
circonscrire il ya d'abord une présence
sécurisante le psychanalyse mon maître
jeunes boulbi qui était président de la
société britannique de psychanalystes
qui a été en difficulté avec la
psychanalyse
qui a été réhabilité à la fin de sa
carrière
john bowlby disait le psychanalyste est
une base de sécurité cet été à partir de
là on parle c'est à dire il faut d'abord
qu'ils une présence sécurisante et là on
a le travail de la parole et les
neurosciences montre aujourd'hui que le
travail de la parole modifie le
fonctionnement du cerveau alors écoutez
catherine millions puisqu'on parle
d'expression je vais prendre l'une de
ses expressions
lacanienne qui a été à la fois pas
comprise provocatrice vous allez nous
dire ce que vous en pensez
je cite là quand il dit le dialogue d'un
sexe à l'autre est interdit il n'y a pas
de rapport sexuel
est ce que c'était de la provocation
surtout qu'on lui faisait reproche même
si c'était à tort d'encourager le
libertinage sexuel
écoutez cette formule il n'y a pas de
rapport sexuel a été pour moi d'une
évidence totale dès que dès que je n'ai
entendu et tout cas des gens et et
d'autres personnes dont j'ai dit par
exemple qui me disait que pour résister
à une formule qu'il horrifié
voilà donc ça dépend des peuples ça
voulait dire quoi il n'y a pas de
rapport sexuel le monde de penser que la
hâte avec la campus a libéré un contre
les hommes et les femmes il n'y a pas de
rapport et pande rapport c'était
d'aignan un incommensurable n'yat il ya
le fait que c'est que ça ne colle pas ça
peut parfois collés mais mon dieu il ya
peu dire quelque chose commune
disharmonie
fondamentale
comparis
comparons ça avec ce qui se passe dans
le règne animal là en général quand il
s'agit pas d'animaux domestiques sont
déjà infectées de la parole
entre les animaux il y à un rapport
sexuel
et si on veut absolument
l'harmonie
jusqu'au bout
l'égalité des sexes alors je crois qu'il
n'a pas d'autre solution que d'être une
bactérie oui là je dire ici elle dit
qu'elle a presque jamais bien de dire
jacquet lumière mais earl modifier un
petit peu chez les animaux il n'y a pas
de rapport mais il ya des actes sexuels
qui sont parfaitement codé à la molécule
près au comportement très
chez les êtres humains ça existe mais
pour qu'il y ait un rapport sexuel il
faudrait aussi qu'il y ait des
représentations de la sexualité
parfaitement analogue ce qui n'est pas
possible puisque on a eu notre jeunesse
un développement différent je parle même
pas des rôles sociaux qui bien sûr était
différent adresse encore dit aujourd'hui
encore différent mais je pense que là je
comprends très bien il n'y a pas de
rapport sexuel parce qu'on a des mondes
manteau différent bien oui dernier nasri
souliers déclic et vous ouvriez
expliquer ce que cette l'ontogénèse
aubaine lourdaud jeunesse et aux cee
développe celle dé la phylogenèse c'est
le développement des organismes vivants
dans sur la planète et l'auto jeunesse
le développement d'un organisme dans son
milieu au moins voilà explique un tueur
daniel mesguich vouliez dire que je
dirais que aussitôt là quand je dirais
que c'est à rapprocher je crois cette
histoire de il n'y a pas de rapport
sexuel à l'amour déjà des réciproque
ce sont des formules relativement
voisine même site l'amour n'est pas le
rapport sexuel je sais pas si boris
cyrulnik aurait été d'accord avec vous
n'avez pas signalé mais on sait par où
les animaux d'un côté et de l'autre je
pense que c'est une seule et même chose
penser que les animaux son départ l'être
aussi non poli bien sûr et je pense que
et je pense que les hommes sont des
animaux comme tout le monde si j'ose
dire mais bon peu importe ce que je veux
simplement dire en tout cas c'est que
c'est que voyez qu'un animal peut faire
une analyse
non mais alors dans ce cas là ça fait la
différence alors pardonnez moi mais dans
ce cas là il ya beaucoup de choses qui
devraient pas pouvoir une psychanalyse
me demandiez tout à l'heure émile ce que
ce que la cour apportait mois pour une
personne qui peut pas moi le sénat vivre
là qu'on disait les vrais catholiques ne
peut pas faire une psychanalyse je
suppose parce que la pratique de la
confession il disait aussi que les
japonais ne pouvait pas faire une
psychanalyse en raison de la structure
de leur langue donc et qu'est ce qu'est
ce qu'ils pensaient des américains par
exemple à
on trouve quand j'étais élève à l'école
normale et que nous étions
althussérienne nous étions ravis par la
critique faisait alors là quand de
l'american way of life et s'est battu
pendant dix ans contre l'interprétation
américaine de la psychanalyse qui était
d'ailleurs fait par des exilés juifs de
l'europe centrale et de l'europe de
l'est dont son propre analystes
rudolf lowenstein oui oui daniel mach
juge j'ai une petite chose c'est un
propos de ce que vient de dire jacques
alain miller il ya beaucoup de choses
alors qu'ils ne peuvent pas être sur le
divan en cure par exemple ce séminaire
qui est devenue célèbre de lacan sur
hamlet puisque ça concerne le théâtre
moi je trouve que ça c'est pas ce qu'il
a fait mieux pour une raison simple
c'est que hamlet n'existe pas
et de la même manière que vous me disiez
que l'on peut pas mettre un chien ou un
cheval sur un divan enfin qu'ils ne
pourraient pas faire une psychanalyse je
ne suis même pas sûr que ça sera pas la
même chose mais ce nom mais je ne suis
pas sûr qu'on puisse pas faire quelque
chose qui se rapprocherait de l'est
c'est un développement vous devriez
donner à l'afrique elle même peu importe
peu importe on entendre on ne
plaisantait pas mais mais mais par
exemple hamlet non plus n'existe pas
voyez enfin en tout cas ne devrait pas
pouvoir faire une psychanalyse alors
vous allez me dire peut-être que freud
lui-même se penche sur hotel tableau de
léonard de vinci ont déduit que léonard
et et homosexuels parce que le vautour à
la place du sexe ont rendu etc etc et
c'est une c'est une livre d'ailleurs que
je trouve absolument génial parce que
ces gens-là du pain est un petit enfant
à côté le fameux du pain de l'un des
trois volets parce que laquelle keller
qu'un inspecteur qu'elle détective
extraordinaire que freud mais sur hamlet
mais déjà je trouve que c'est abusif
parce que
qu'est-ce qu'ils économisent prude l'art
tout simplement il fait comme si
directement c'est l inconscient de notre
camarade léonard de vinci qui avait pas
non c'est pas comme ça que ça marche il
ya un artiste entre les deux et cet
artiste là on empêche qu'on puisse dire
voilà ce qu'il lui a volé ce qui lui
échappe pas ça c'est son inconscient ça
s'est passé
et quant à hamlet je ne pense pas et
quant à hamlet alors c'est encore pire
si j'ose dire parce que le vice et s'est
même pas shakespeare c'est carrément
personne c'est un montage d'écriture de
la en des lieux qu'il est hystérique la
montage d'écriture hystérique jamais vu
ça bien côté pourra lui dans votre sens
lacan presque deux derniers lacan a dit
l'artiste précède toujours le psy
quesnel oui mais sait il l'a dit comme
tous les théoriciens c'est à dire en
disant je suis tellement fort que je
peux laisser la place de leader à
l'autre de toute manière je me pencherai
sur son oeuvre et quand on est si au
dessous on peut difficilement se pencher
pour aller dans votre sens encore il est
vrai que marguerite duras à qui il avait
consacré un article sur lol veste un
marc de rue du razes a
repoussé cette construction de lacq en
disant qu'elle n'y comprenez rien c'est
ça je l' ai entendu de la bouche et
s'est pas formalisé dès que j'avais un
mot à dire là dessus sur cette
controverse boris cyrulnik
non je pense effectivement que lorsque
ce freud interpréter
l'homosexualité léonard de vinci
avec cette ce vautour qui dit caresse
les lèvres avec les plumes de la queue
jeu pour que c'était une interprétation
un peu hardie un peu amusantes mais
magnifique d'autre part alors les
premières interprétations magnifique
c'est une interprétation il refuse
[Musique]
alors il vient d'avoir une citation de
karl jaspers
une pensée qui éclaire n'est pas un
savoir qu'on peut employer la formation
des psychanalystes suscite
l'interrogation des pouvoirs publics il
n'y a pas de diplôme d'état ni de
reconnaissance universitaire jacques
lacan a institué la passe pour permettre
l'exercice de la psychanalyse de quoi
s'agit-il et le plus simplement possible
jacques adam hier écoutez j'ai d'abord
envie de vous dit que lacan dans sa
thèse était jasper siens tutelle dernier
cri à l'époque de la psychopathologie et
ensuite il n'a eu de cesse qu de crise
méchamment critiqué
jaspers en disant que c'était l'erreur
que la compréhension et l erreur à ne
pas commettre
voilà en tout cas un mot pour jaspers
alors les psychanalystes
n'ont jamais pu préciser exactement
la fin d'une cité neil à la fois aller
le moment où elle doit se terminer
si je puis dire légalement ou logique on
va en parler après mais là on est dans
le bon sens ça n'est pas la patte alors
ça lol
on le savait pas freud lui même dit dans
un de ses derniers articles que sas
finit quand l'un et l'autre le
psychanalyste et son patient sont
satisfaits l'un de l'autre que ça s'est
bien passé c'est pas une réponse
extrêmement précises l'a conduit à
penser qu'il pouvait donner
une forme ou tout à fait prêt 6 2 cette
fin d'année ghz
après avoir donné la formule du
commencement vues entre les deux comme
aux échecs
c'est une autre affaire mais on peut y
aller les débuts de partie aux échecs il
ya les fun party donc il a comparé sa et
il a pensé qu' on pouvait vérifier en
écoutant le patient qui pensent avoir
fini qu'on pouvait vérifier si c'était
vrai ou pas
disons qu'il a été plus sceptiques sur
sa propre construction
vers la fin de sa vie ça aurait été
mieux de boris cyrulnik
à part la réussite et nous va vous est
fréquemment daniel mesguich de boris
cyrulnik sur la question de la passe la
formation des psychanalystes qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
il est
un peu éloigné en tant que
neuropsychiatre mais en même temps vous
avez une idée de 7 aujourd'hui on est
une analyse vous avez fait une analyse
elle était la tan yens pardonner mais
oui elle était l'un kahnienne
donc un business même pas hétérodoxes
sur ce plateau elle
si si si je suis moi j'ai une autre
lecture de la campus que et profitez-en
pour nous la donner en même temps à
travers la question de la passe alors à
travers la question de la passe je pense
que
c'est mes collègues qui se sont formés à
la psycho à l'abc d'alcaniz qui n'est
pas tout à fait la même que la
psychanalyse
mais colin de laon un petit peu abusé
avec la passe c'est à dire que il ya une
formation et téoria une formation il n'y
a pas d'enseignement rayonne formation
on se forme à la psychanalyse après une
expérience vécue on arrive à un autre un
autre mode de compréhension c'est pas
attendez c'est pas la compréhension
intellectuelle c'est là qu'on prend
c'est la compréhension et prouver c'est
à dire qu'à mon sens la plus belle la
plus importante mais il y avait beaucoup
de gens qui se sont qui ont utilisé
cette notion de passe pour aller un peu
trop loin et faire des passes un peu
trop rapide
mais sur la notion de passe ça vous
parle quelque chose oui c'est une phrase
le camp c'est une âme une expression de
la canche pas trop apprécié parce que
mais c'est l'expression du milieu
lacanien bon j'aurais préféré rencontre
boulbi par les deux rencontres très bien
alors ma vie je voudrais que vous
précisiez quelque chose maury cyrulik
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
neurosciences la psychiatre on parle de
psychiatrie cognitive la pharmacopée les
médicaments sont très en vogue et cetera
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
tendance là va l'emporter sur la
psychanalyse ce que c'est on voit des
titres des journaux la psychanalyse va
disparaître et cetera est-ce que vous
pensez que la neuroscience est en train
de grappiller le capital intellectuel de
la psychanalyse alors j'espère vous
surprend mais je pense au contraire que
le neuro chance confirme un grand nombre
d'hypothèses psychanalytique en infirme
quelques-unes et ans confirme beaucoup
je pense que par exemple la fait l'effet
de la parole sur le cerveau matteau une
photographie c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
parle autour d'un bébé le lobe temporal
go traite les sons pas les mots
lorsqu'on s'adresse à un bébé c'est une
zone précise du lobe temporal bourse le
planeur temporal un repli précis qui
dégage de l'énergie c'est à dire que
s'adresser à un bébé s'est sculpté son
cerveau donc assez paradoxalement
beaucoup c'est pas 100% c'est jamais
sans pour soir et sciences humaines mais
la neuroscience aube rouge pas à la
psychanalyse à des diminué par exemple
la horde primitive est complètement
disqualifié par l'éthologie animal la
théorie freudienne de la horde primitive
en revanche un très grand normes
d'hypothèses de pratique psychanalytique
sont confirmés sont illustrés par les
neurosciences alors la même question
avoue jacques alain miller vous craignez
que les neurosciences l'emportent et est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec boris
cyrulnik sur cette complémentarité
quasiment biologique entre psychanalyse
et neurosciences
entrer dans le détail je suis ravi
d'entendre
pornic
dire ce qu'il dit je voudrais préciser
une chose sur le mot de la passe qui en
france est aaa deseco et peut-être pas
tous ceux du bon goût c'est au fond je
pense que lacan faisait référence à ce
que freud posait comme ceux qui
empêchent la conclusion d'une
psychanalyse à savoir une impasse
qui est d'ailleurs différentes pour les
hommes et pour les femmes
annonce 2 n'a pas de rapport sexuel est
là qu on pensait que non il n'y avait
pas un passe une passe était possible au
sens maritime où ce que monsieur
mélenchon appelle un trou de souris très
bien et sur neurosciences et
psychanalyse vous pensez que c'est
compatible au jour où il ya tible avec
les neuroscientifiques qui sont anti pas
avec le neuroscientifique zones riches à
donner ce que vous venez de la haie
alors bannie vous trouvez que boris
cyrulnik est un gentil neuropathique
gentil intelligent
vous acceptez pas vous êtes méfiant
boris et réunit donc je me pose la
question un peu différemment c'est à
dire qu'il s'agit pas de confirmer ou
d'infirmer y cergy de découvrir et de
comprendre donc confirmer ou infirmer la
psychanalyse par les neurosciences et
une démarche idéologique
or j'ai été praticiens c'est à dire que
j'ai en tant que praticien j'ai été
content de savoir que ce que j'avais
compris en psychanalyse était confiant
et pas toujours mais confirmée par les
neurosciences mélange des neurosciences
et pas de confirmer la psychanalyse de
même que l'enjeu de l'éthologie animal
c'est pas de dire que les hommes sont
des animaux c'est à dire que les hommes
sont des animaux parlants c'est à dire
que c'est une eau parmi on est dans le
monde vivant on est des êtres vivants on
a tous été des mammifères aquatiques
pendant neuf mois c'est à dire que tous
on a baigné par l'océan pendant avec
comme fait ringue mais oui comme un cri
on a baigné on a tous été des femelles
pendant 14 jours les 14 premiers jours
de notre développement et contrairement
à ce que dit simone de beauvoir certains
une petite moitié d'entre nous sont
devenus les mâles et une autre moitié
sont restés les femelles c'est à dire
que mais ça donc c'est blanc jeu on est
des êtres de biologie et parmi les
animaux vivants on est des agglomérats
je suis très content de cette discussion
parce que connu sans enjeu jean pierre
changeux la jce je vous ai même trouvé
le titre l'homme neuronal dans un
entretien que j'ai eu avec elle rit
danse hérité forte intelligente but est
quand même la psychanalyste comme une
discipline pas du tout sérieux en tout
cas écoutait cette discussion est
extrêmement intéressante mais comme le
temps imparti est écoulé je vous
demandais même très brièvement peut-être
en un mot en conclusion de de nous dire
ce que vous pensez lacan partager avec
freud une absence d'illusions sur le
genre humain il était par ailleurs
méfiants envers les institutions ses
disciples les disciples à gagne 1 sont
nombreux mais en deux mots jacques alain
miller est ce qu'ils cherchaient à faire
école ah oui et derrière alors qu'on
employait le mot d'associations ou de
sociétés jusqu'à lui en
1964 il a choisi d'appeler le monde qui
étaient autour de lui une école et je
pense à part moi que le fai calcus air
l'avait invité à faire des conférences à
l'école normale supérieure
pour laquelle il avait à la fois du
respect et beaucoup de moqueries je
pense que ça l'a inspiré pour donner à
son groupe
le nom d'école donc on est bien d'accord
catherine millot vous avait fréquenté
lacan pendant ces dernières années vous
confirmez qu'il voulait faire école
ça c'est certain c'est certain qu'il
était enfin que vous voulez faire école
et qu'il voulait vingt étaient très
préoccupés par la transmission et par la
transmission de son enseignement et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il était
qu'il a été je crois très soulagé de ce
que jacques alain effet la transcription
de ces séminaires et qui ont pu être
publiés au début des années 70 ça st
c'était pour lui une préoccupation
ça a été une préoccupation constante sa
merci et côtés de lorie 90 ans à la fin
de sa vie il n'y a pas de transmission
de la psychanalyse pour prendre à revers
tous ces élèves bien bah écoute et voilà
ça sera on restera sur ses derniers mots
je voudrais maintenant vous présentez
une bibliographie alors vient de sortir
lacan redit vivus c'est un peu ce que
nous avons parlé ce dont nous avons
parlé au cours de cette émission
pourquoi vous l'avez fait en deux mots
jacques un ami l'air parce qu'ils
marchaient daraa leader ou ses proches
se sont tus sur la camp alors que se
répandait un portrait biaisé et
détestable est inexact là quand au bout
de quarante ans je pense qu'il était
temps il était nécessaire que ses
proches par le change de politique et
parle de lui très bien jacques alain
miller toujours vous publié chez le même
éditeur navarre un éditeur comment
finissent les analyses coûtait vous
l'avez on en a parlé au cours de cette
émission
boris cyrulnik
vous venez de faire paraître le
laboureur et les mangeurs devant chez
odile jacob
c'est pas les bons et les méchants mais
est ce qu'ils réfléchissent et ceux qui
prennent n'importe quelle idée reçue
pour la vérité c'est bien c'est ça mon
amour et pourquoi vous l'avez fait
est-ce que vous pensez que cette époque
à travers internet les réseaux sociaux
ne distillent que défectueuse
parce que je pense depuis mon enfance
que je suis je un thème qui à thématiser
ma vie c'est pourquoi certains se
soumettent à une théorie délirante coupé
du réel qui peut être logique de délire
logique ça existe c'est à dire que par
exemple esclavage c'est un délire
logique si on supprime les esclavages ça
va augmenter le prix du sucre c'est vrai
c'est logique ça repose sur un postulat
qu'on criminels coupé de la réalité
sensible donc depuis mon enfant je suis
fasciné par ce genre de problème donc 85
ans plus tard ça donne ce livre merci
monsieur le laboureur vori cyrulnik
alors catherine millot la vie avec lacan
c'est une partie de la vie que vous avez
partagé avec lacan oui enfin c'est mais
c'est aussi la vie avec lacan sais pas
ce n'est pas ma vie à l'éclat quand j'ai
écrit la vie avec la cause parce que je
voulais témoigner puisque tu avais été
là vie autant de lacan autant bougé
pendant la période où j'ai connu lacan
était des années folles les années 70
c'était c'était de belles années et la
présence de la cançon ne son
enseignement ce moment là c'était
quelque chose de daikin extrêmement
dynamique et de ti vct inquiète qui
était qui suscitait le désir de tout le
monde jusqu'au point de tout ce qu'il
dit qui le suivent et son souvenir vous
êtes toujours présent à tout à fait
fruits et daniel mesguich
estuaire c'est un peu énigmatique chez
gallimard
foyer gothique et oui c'est super
pourquoi c'est là où vous tous les
fleuves se rejoignent et alors qu'est ce
que vous faites se rejoindre dans ce
texte ce contexte la vie avec eux non la
vie avec moi
même ou avec le théâtre avec le théâtre
vérité oui oui bien sûr c'est la passion
de votre vie sa colonne vertébrale la
colère ça n'est pas forcément la chaire
d autres choses très bien donc un
stupeur chez gallimard et goûter il me
reste à vous remercier en acier
catherine millions d'agnelles mai guiche
boris cyrulnik jacques muller et avant
de nous quitter je vous laisse avec
cette citation de jacques lacan plus
exactement une présentation de malades
par jacques lacan
[Musique]